families gather outside a prison in
myanmar's commercial capital yangon
hoping to be reunited with their loved
ones
the military junta freed 600 people
including criminals and foreign
nationals as part of an annual amnesty
to mark the buddhist new year but
political prisoners were not included
my daughter was arrested on the 25th of
april 2021 and sent for interrogation
she was sentenced to three years in
prison on a political charge now she's
been in prison for more than a year
the military seized power in february
last year just a few months after an
sansuchi's national league for democracy
swept to power
within days of the coup protesters were
on the streets demanding her release and
a return to civilian rule
a campaign of civil disobedience
followed which triggered a deadly
crackdown by security forces
since then thousands of protesters have
been arrested and jailed the military's
arrested an astonishing number of people
since the coup in february of last year
so there's a there's about 13 000 people
who are political prisoners in myanmar
they're in jail for any perceived
opposition to the coup so peaceful
protesters
if you carried a banner that that
suggested you weren't happy with the
coup you could be sentenced to a
considerable period of time in jail
human rights groups say the junta uses
political prisoners as bargaining chips
freeing them from time to time to
appease countries critical of the coup
for these families it means more
uncertainty not knowing when they'll see
their relatives again
victoria gatenbee al jazeera